bed Sorensen is a technical cave driver
on standby to go to Thailand if needed
he serves as a coordinator with
international underwater cave rescue and
recovery and is also a safety officer
for the National SPEA logical societies
cave diving section he joins us from
Florida's Blue Springs State Park ed
good to see you thank you so much from
joining us you just heard Ben Tracy
there on the ground saying the second
operation is under walk underway and
that a source telling him this morning
they hope to get six more boys out today
what are the risks and the dangers to
the boys and the drivers well there's
just so many risks in a rescue operation
such as this one the obviously the zero
vis is one of the biggest the flow
extreme high flow on this particular
case the flow seems to be dropping down
so little that should help them out a
little bit but the that the narrow
restrictions are one of going to be one
of the biggest ones stress is one thing
that they really need to keep in mind
these boys aren't used to being in the
water they don't even know how to swim
they haven't had Skoob apparatus on and
then to have to get separated from their
rescuer and then get stuck through a
small hole it's going to be stressful
for them what are you focusing on that
you know as a layperson we're just
saying go please hurry get them out as
quickly as they can when you hear the
operation and it's underway what are you
focusing on that says to you this is
going well or there's houston we have a
problem here well so many people don't
understand that just being in an
overhead is extremely stressful for most
people and for these kids
we don't even let people start cave
training until they're at least 18 years
of age and there's a reason for that so
these kids are so young plus they're
supposed to have a good comfort level in
the water before they can start these
kids don't even know how to swim
they haven't been even open water scuba
trained so they've just got and like
every obstacle against them so they're
beating all the odds so far and it's
just fantastic that they've had such a
great outcome so far and if you had to
teach me quickly and I was one of these
boys how to get three
five hours what would you tell me to at
least give me some kind of chance in
this well I can't do that because that
would speculate of what they're doing so
basically I would tell those boys that
they just need to listen to everything
that rescuers say and just be strong and
and get through this all right ed
Sorenson thanks so much for your
expertise